okay one of my favorite parts about our
signature segment designed by drew is
helping redesign spaces for those who
give back to everybody else and nobody
works harder supporting others than
first responders
[Applause]
so
kat lewis has made history or herstory
as we now say as the first career female
firefighter in the city of long beach
new york she and her fellow firefighters
put their lives on the line every single
day
i was lucky enough to meet them take a
look
as a young girl i always wanted to be a
firefighter my name is catherine lewis
and most people here call me cat
the long beach fire department has
existed for almost 100 years but i am
the first career female firefighter a
lot of people are used to seeing the
fire truck drive by and seeing four guys
in the back but now they see my ponytail
and they immediately light up with a
smile she's going to show so many young
girls that anything could be
accomplished she broke
the glass ceiling
kat is like a daughter to me i admire
pretty much everything about her she's
exceptional the fact that she's a
division one college athlete she has a
master's degree she crushed the entrance
exam she did amazing on the physical
agility you know there were days where
we didn't have an instructor for pt and
kat became the unofficial pt instructor
for the entire academy of all men not
only does she hold her own she excels
the firehouse is a home away from home
we definitely spend a lot of time
together in the den we spend holidays
birthdays anniversaries at the firehouse
the fire service is not just a
brotherhood now it's more like a
brotherhood and sisterhood it's a family
i couldn't be more proud of all the
people that i work with i know that
they're going to do everything that they
can to protect the city of long beach i
think as a firefighter
most people get into the job because
they want to save lives we're here to
save lives but we're here to help people
on their worst day i would love for
young girls to see me and think oh wow i
could be a firefighter too
[Applause]
any man woman or child is going to watch
you cat and dream and think about
possibilities and hopefully you know
trying to rise to the occasion the way
that you have and also your family the
other members from the long beach fire
department are here today
hi guys
why did you want to be this female first
responder set the bar set the tone
yeah so i mean i've always wanted to be
a firefighter growing up i didn't know
many female firefighters so i view it as
a privilege right now to be a role model
for young girls and and young kids just
see you know you could do whatever you
want to do as long as you put hard work
into it and persevere
[Applause]
[Music]
and you guys we talked about how you
spend time with the people you work with
in ways that's you know completely equal
if not sometimes tips the scale of the
time you spend with your family and it
does make you a family and a family
deserves a beautiful space especially
one that takes care of everybody else
so um well we have a little fun surprise
um check it out
[Music]
here we go
hi cat and company how you guys doing
hey drew
i like surprises
i am in awe
of what you do
so
i'm not even gonna pretend like i could
do what you do
but i do love design
i was looking around your space and i
was wondering if you guys would be open
to doing a design by drew which is a
segment we do here on our show
and i could make over your space no way
oh my gosh
yes we need it we need it drew we need
it
i think your place has so much soul
and it does have really good cozy vibes
so i'd love to try and make it something
that feels fresh and new but really
keeps
the personality that's already there and
you do frat house leftover sheep
the place is built i believe in the
early 70s and other than a couple coats
of paint over the years that really has
that much i'd like to have your back
in any capacity the way you have
everybody else's back that's so cool
thank you so much drew i can't wait to
get started
[Applause]
this table we want to preserve that
because it's really special yeah that
has to stay but we need new chairs
i like this reference because this felt
kind of like
a hotel vibe it's almost like a hotel
lobby-esque type of feel that's elevated
and also
there are shipping problems in the
country with the ports and some of the
stuff we were liking originally is just
simply not available so these are the
two floor plans that i had created i do
like some individual chairs in case you
don't want to buddy up sometimes they're
there for days and weeks and they have
to spend the night there so like they
want a little break away from each other
so i thought this was a nice way to kind
of break things up i love it i'm liking
this this is gonna be a very swanky
lounge i can't think of anyone who
deserves it more i'm not gonna let you
down it's gonna be beautiful
[Applause]
um okay we're gonna go to a quick
commercial break but i gotta tell you my
design partner in crime mikael welch
i'm really excited about what we came up
with
[Music]
you